a school in mourning for a beloved
teacher rest in peace mr. furlong thank
you for everything you taught me
James furlong was among three people
killed in a stabbing in Redding on
Saturday described as a kind and gentle
man he'd been enjoying an evening in the
park when terror struck pupils past and
present in disbelief
everyone's devastated were been crying
because obviously some of my friends
were his form cheater
he wasn't their form tutor and obviously
you see him every day
and just thought that he's not gonna be
here anymore is quite a sad sad you made
history something that we all enjoy
you were the face of the history
department and we all really loved you
you'd have inside jokes with each and
every one of us you'd put smiles on our
faces it's just I can't I can't believe
it quite honestly his death now treated
as part of a terrorist incident a 25
year old Libyan man under arrest on
suspicion of murder from our inquiries
undertaken so far officers have found
nothing to suggest that there was anyone
else involved in this attack and
presently we are not looking for anyone
else in relation to the incident our
priority will always be to ensure there
is no outstanding threat to members of
the public this is where the suspected
knife man granted asylum in the UK was
believed to be living it's understood he
was briefly on the radar of mi5 last
year but there wasn't enough concern to
launch a full investigation the scene on
Saturday night as armed police raided
the flat neighbors shocked scared
possibly scared really really scared
scared for myself and my children
because
to here there's terrorists inside build
and you know and we're not allowed to
eat outfield and it's scary
the man's believed to have lived on the
third floor of this council block the
suspects actual flat is believed to be
beyond that door we can't get any closer
but there is evidence of the raid
there's some debris on the floor and
even ear defenders presumably worn by
the officers who came here this man said
he knew the suspect who's been named as
KY Risa dalla Kieran numers k he was so
normal and I never would expect him to
do that did he talk in any like express
interest in Islamic state or nothing no
Islamic state and never suppress
interest in harming or doing anything to
anyone he was just just generally such a
happy chilled guy from what I saw the
attack on this park in Redding is being
treated as a terrorist incident the
Prime Minister mindful he may face
uncomfortable questions I'm appalled and
sickened that people should lose their
lives in this way and I thought so very
much with the the families and friends
of the of the victims if there are
lessons that we need to learn about how
we handle such cases how we handle the
events leading up to such cases then we
will learn those lessons and we will not
hesitate to take action when necessary
slim comfort for those affected by this
latest atrocity no lessons here on
Monday at mr. furlong school students
shaken by coronavirus now stricken with
grief
Deborah Haynes Sky News reading